as you guys probably know we do film
this show on thursday and not friday and
uh a lot of big things are happening
today
taylor swift new signal katy perry in
your video queen's the stone age new
album
my word what a big day but we're not
going to talk about any of that instead
we're going to talk about the top five
news stories in video games this week
that's right
final fantasy xv is coming to pc and a
lot of people are talking about you know
the file size came out and it was
apparently really big and then hajime
tvada game director was like no no it's
not actually that size that was a
mistake
um so some things like that are
happening which are expected and then
some other things are being discussed
which are less expected
yeah i actually have a question about
the pc version of final fantasy 15.
i like to play video games with mods uh
in particular we all do uh i'd be really
interested to know if final fantasy 15
will allow me to have nude mods
well it absolutely will and uh
apparently a lot of people have had this
question
and you know tabata has come out to
address it and been pretty frank to say
if you all want your nude mods you can
have your nude vlogs um he's told pc
gamers and
that basically it's a thing that people
were worried about that people brought
to them
saying uh is this an okay thing are you
guys going to allow this
and they've been really frank about it
and said look
when you buy that game it's your game
and it's pc and pc supports mods and if
you want to mod it
put it however you want i believe he
used the phrase we're going to leave it
up to the moral compass of the gamers
so clearly he hasn't been on the
internet at all ever in his life
so i can't wait for all the still images
to be coming out
for final fantasy xv and those four
dudes just running around hanging brain
yeah amazing that's a phrase i wish
wasn't in this news episode and i may or
may not believe
but uh do let us know what you think of
this one in that comment box
destiny 2 is coming out soon and it's
coming to pc as well as consoles but
it's going to be running at 30 frames
per second
on console but apparently it doesn't
have to
but they're going to make it run at 30
anyway they are mark noseworthy the
executive producer explains to edge
magazine why it runs at 30 frames per
second on console
and it's because it basically boils down
to it's the only way they could make the
game that they really want to make
yeah so he's basically said you know if
they did want to get it running at 60
frames per second
the space would be smaller it'd be less
cooperative and there'd be fewer
monsters to shoot
and he said that's not the game they
want to make which is fine i mean i'm
i'm perfectly fine with 30 frames per
second stuff i know a lot of people
aren't a lot of people do enjoy 60
frames per second
uh games especially when it comes to
multiplayer but i get it
obviously if you have a console and you
you want it to run at 60 frames per
second
that that choice would be amazing but it
does sound like the destiny
is technically limited on consoles and
that's why it's running at 30 which
you know nothing that can be done
unfortunately
while we're in the realm of multiplayer
shooters let's talk about overwatch
there's been a bunch of stuff announced
this week heaps of changes
new map new short came out so i'm going
to give you a quick overview of some of
those we've covered a little bit of that
in earlier episodes of news if you want
to check them out
but mainly diva and mercy are getting
new abilities uh diva's defense matrix
is being nerfed and she's getting the
ability to shoot while she uses her
boosters and she's getting some missiles
which is pretty cool
mercy is getting a brand new ultimate
her resurrection ultimate has now become
an ability
and her new ultimate is called valkyrie
as she gets based she becomes the angel
of death she gets uh healing and
damage boosts she gets unlimited ammo
and she can fly around the map it's
gonna be crazy and then there's the new
map that's set in australia called
junkertown
pretty excited about that can't wait to
play a map set in australia that isn't
the
weird lucioball sydney opera house yes
definitely um
but there's been a bit of a controversy
about about a sign
in the trailer yes so uh the sign
says and this is one of the biggest
stories of the week
i'm sorry the sign says
take out and in australia we call
takeout takeaway
look it's one of those like funny gripes
that i think some people have like
decided to hang their hat on because
it's like
funny to get upset about i don't think
anyone's genuinely really upset about it
but
blizzard went and apologized to
australia anyway
uh because of the oversight so yeah the
oversight in overwatch
that's right thank god there was no sign
for potato scallops or potato cakes
because that would have opened up a
whole can of worms that's true
although what did open up a can of worms
not a good segue
was uh if the worms were our tears the
new may short wow super adorable
yeah check it out if you haven't already
the overwatch animated shorts are great
and there is a new one about
may and uh set at eco point and
antarctica which is
definitely worth your time or may every
day
you may remember from e3 2016 ea
announced a very very pretty looking
indie game called fee
we now know that that game's coming out
next year and it's coming to
pc xbox one ps4 and switch yeah it's
supposed to be out early in the year
and i think switch users are just super
excited that they're going to be able to
get their hands on this one as well we
knew it was going to all the other
platforms
but the fact that it's going to be on
switch is really exciting for people who
want to play this very outdoorsy nature
heavy game outside
totally the creative lead uh in a press
release said we would spend hours in the
woods as kids and while it felt scary at
first eventually the strange sounds
became familiar
you'll become part of nature and the
forest feels like home players will
realize the similar feelings as they
play through feet so if you don't know
fee is basically a game where you place
a cub
who explores the forest and interacts
with the forest animals and it's all
super adorable that sounds lovely i'm
actually excited to get this one on
switch because i played
basically all the indie games that i
used to play and still play i play a lot
of my vita
stuff like down well super meat boy yeah
uh
that spelunky one so i'm really excited
to be able to have that on a handheld i
just find that to i can sink into them a
little bit better on a handheld i don't
know why
it's got an awful lonely in here and
that's because we're about to talk about
sports i know nothing about sports
jessica clearly knows something about
sports and that's why she's subbed in
with the guy who knows a little bit
about sports eddie makuu here he is
what's up dan i don't know why i clicked
um we're here to talk about nba 2k18 and
apparently they're cover star yeah so
this is a really interesting and awkward
situation for uh 2k sports so about a
couple uh
or earlier this summer uh kyrie irving
who was announced as the cover star for
nba 2k18 said or there were reports
about him wanting to be traded
which put the game at an interesting and
awkward position and now that has
actually happened he was traded to the
boston celtics
which is a team that is near and dear to
my heart
and yes so kyrie irving in a cleveland
cavaliers jersey is still going to be on
the cover um of the game
but that's not the team that he plays
for okay okay that seems like a various
what what's
they gonna do are they gonna are they
gonna reprint these and send them out
free to everyone who buys a copy of nba
2k18
remains to be seen they put out a
statement saying you know
uh these things happen it's the nature
of a live sport game and they even
patted themselves on the back
a bit i'm saying that you know we are at
nimble companies and we're allowed to
we have the opportunity you know to make
these decisions but 2k is going to put
out a version
of the game with kyrie in a celtics
jersey so if people are looking for that
then they'll be able to get it and
in canada demar derozan of the toronto
raptors is on the cover and shaquille
o'neal is on the cover of their like
legendary
so multiple covers anyway uh let me
pitch this to you 2k you make up a bunch
of stickers
that are just a new jersey and you have
them only available
at nba games and that's like some viral
marketing for you and all social
stickers
that is everything we've got for you
guys this week thank you so much for
joining us
as always to let us know what you
thought of today's stories in that
comment box and we will be back
on your little screens whether they be
mobile pc or otherwise on monday
don't make fun of our postal football
and go yeah it keeps falling down sorry
goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye